great britain's female gymnastics team
overturned almost a century of history
when they won a bronze in the team event
a little earlier today
it's first time in fact since 1928 that
they have managed a medal in the event
and came amid upset for the favorites of
the united
states the team was made up of alice
kinsella emily morgan and twins jennifer
and jessica gadarova and i'm delighted
to say we can speak to the coach for the
gadda rovers
molly richardson who joins us now
goodness
uh pretty exciting times aren't they
these
oh yes absolutely amazing um
we're absolutely over the moon so um i'm
on cloud nine at the moment
it has to be said they weren't expected
to secure a medal really were they
so they qualified in sixth um
so to come out with a bronze medal
is absolutely incredible um i couldn't
say that we
you know we was expecting it um so
yeah i'm absolutely amazed um
so yeah it's absolutely amazing for all
the gymnasts um
especially after a challenging year with
covid
and everything like that it's great to
see the the gymnast back out on the big
stage
how did all that impact your training
then i'm
guessing you're going to have had
setbacks in the past few months
yeah so i think for all the gymnasts
there was
definitely setbacks um there was a
moment where they had to do
um training at home um so that
definitely had its
ups and downs
to um into the gym um at some capacity
just to keep their level of fitness
going
um and everything so we were super lucky
um you know to be able to still train
and
um yeah work up to the olympics is
where we are today so it's it's crazy
does that suggest that perhaps some of
these athletes aren't as prepared as
they ought to be
going into the games
um possibly um
i think it really just depends in each
individual
and depending where they train if
they're
in what facility where they're allowed
to train and things like that so
um it really just depends on each
gymnast
i think most of the gymnasts would have
been able to
continue training whether if whether it
was
at home or in the gym um they probably
did do
something so so yeah right while you're
on we must of course talk about
jennifer and jessica who are they
they've catapulted to stardom today
um so yeah they're 16 year old twin
sisters
um they live in ellsbury which is where
our club is
um i work alongside my brother josh um
so we're also siblings teaching siblings
um
and i think that's an actual big factor
on why
it is such a good team and they
are getting success at the moment and we
do that
so so well and we're really really close
um so yeah
i know they were really looking forward
to paris 2024
never thought they'd get a medal in
these championships
these games were they realistically
no so um this olympics
was definitely out of um the unexpected
and like you mentioned we were planning
on and for paris
um but i think that's one positive that
we have taken out of covid they
you know after the olympics being pushed
back a year
they got that extra year just to get a
little bit more difficulty in their
skills
and just get that little bit of extra
preparation which has
um allowed them to get to where they are
today so um
i know covid has been super super
like devastating for everybody but um
that is one thing where it has been
really positive
and um yeah we're very very grateful for
this moment
come on come on while you're on i just
want to talk about perhaps a mental
pressure on some of the athletes
you may be aware what's happened to
simone biles
uh she has uh pulled out today so
perhaps a huge pressure quite quite a
big toll on people taking part in
competition
yeah i think um just in any sport you do
there's going to be
a certain level of pressure and
um it's clear to say i'm sure every
gymnast
in the arena today was experienced some
kind of pressure and
like anxiety and things um but the
amount of support that british
gymnastics
gives to the girls and gives to us as
coaches
and just the general support and love
that we've had from
everybody um is absolutely amazing so
um thank you to all those people as well
actually i'd like to say
so um without them guys um we won't be
where we are today but um yeah i did see
simone that
pulled out today um i think one of her
landings was just
a little bit too hard um on her vault in
i'm not too sure
um i know she said it was a medical
issue so hopefully
she might be back out in the next few
days but we'll have to wait and see i
guess
well we can't take away from the success
of jennifer
and jessica and the other two can we uh
olympic bronze for team gb molly
richardson thanks very much indeed for
your time thank you for having me
you're very welcome thank you